lo que estábamos haciendo en el vídeo
anterior era concentrarnos en esta
especie de superficie exterior o más
bien vivía lateral de esta especie de
como de cilindro cortado y descubrimos
que con esta parametrización que vimos
aquí
pudimos calcular a de ese de ese era el
la norma del producto cruz de las
derivadas parciales de la
parametrización verdad así que de hecho
de ese se simplifica simplemente 1
entonces ahora ya estamos listos para
calcular la integral de superficie y
déjenme volverla a anotar
la integral
la más abajito era la integral sobre la
superficie s 2 de zeta de s muy bien
entonces esto será igual si recordamos y
se mueve entre 0 y 2 pi y b se mueve
entre 0 y 1 - coseno de eeuu entonces el
hecho de que b tenga un límite superior
que depende de la otra variable y eso se
debe a que pues por ejemplo b que era la
altura pues no es la misma si estamos
por ejemplo en esta región que si
estamos por acá atrás verdad entonces lo
que nos conviene es integrar primero
respecto debe para que uno de los
límites superiores nos quede respecto de
eeuu y luego el segundo el límite que o
más bien la segunda variable que vamos a
integrar eso que está entre 0 y 2 pi
déjenme déjenme ponerlo para que sea
mucho más claro
esto será igual a la integral de 0 a 2
la integral de la integral de 0 a 1
coseno de un 1 menos coseno de v de
quien pues era de zeta que esencialmente
es ve en nuestra parametrización y
primero integramos respecto de de y
luego respecto
dv entonces como ven esta parte de aquí
depende de eeuu y que eso nos permite
que integremos después respecto de eeuu
entonces esto simplemente va a ser igual
esto va a ser igual a la integral de 0 a
2 para la integral de 0 a 2 p del line
de la anti derivada o de la primitiva
debe pero quien es una primitiva debe
eso es muy sencillo porque eso es de
cuadrada entre 2 esto es de cuadrada
sobre 2 y esto hay que evaluarlo desde
cero a uno menos coseno de eeuu y esto
es de uno
ok esto ya fue simplemente haber
resuelto este integral morada pero bueno
esto simplemente será igual
esto será igual a la integral de 0 a 2
pi de si evaluamos en uno menos coseno
de unos queda ya desarrollado es uno
menos coseno de walt cuadrado que es uno
menos dos veces coseno de eeuu más
coseno de seno de al cuadrado
ok todo esto dv y nos falta de evaluar
bueno multiplicar por un medio verdad
esto es por un medio
un medio
hay que integrarlo respecto dv
de hecho déjenme sacar en un medio en un
medio mejor que se quede de este lado
lo quitamos de aquí lo ponemos mejor acá
ok entonces esto resultó simplemente
devaluar uno menos coseno de walt
cuadrado verdad el primero al cuadrado
menos dos veces el primero por el
segundo que está más el segundo al
cuadrado y luego restamos esto evaluado
en cero pero eso es cero por eso ya no
puse nada más entonces si seguimos esto
esto va a ser igual esto es igual a un
medio
en medio de quién es bueno hay que
multiplicar esto está íntegra la podemos
distribuir verdad es la suma de las
integrales entonces va a ser la integral
de 0 a 2 pi de 1 que es por dv entonces
simplemente nos queda esto más el 2 de
aquí lo podemos sacar y nos queda dos
veces la integral de 0 a 2 pi de él y de
hecho aquí no es más verdad aquí es un
menos
aquí son menos
será menos 2 la integral de 0 a 2 pitt
del coseno de v dv y ahora sí más la
integral de 0 a 2 pi del coseno cuadrado
de v
que antes de hacerlo déjenme hacer algo
porque calcular la anti derivada del
coseno cuadrado de v es es bastante
difícil digamos bueno no es que no es
inmediato de cómo hacerlo entonces lo
que podemos hacer es que el coche no de
eeuu no podemos expresar todo esto lo
podemos expresar de otra forma lo
podemos expresar como un medio más un
medio coseno de 2 le sugiero que si no
se acuerdan de esto vean los videos de
identidades trigonométricas entonces
ésta es lo que nos va a permitir
calcular una anti derivada más sencilla
porque la anti derivada de un medio es
fácil y la anti derivada de coseno de 2
también es relativamente fácil entonces
esto será la integral de un medio más un
medio coseno de 2
aunque todo esto respecto de v y todo
esto lo está multiplicando en un medio
de acá afuera entonces vamos a resolver
cada uno de ellos por ejemplo aquí la
anti derivada de dv
pues eso es muy sencillo esto
simplemente va a ser y esto será
evaluado de 0 a 2 p entonces sabemos que
en 0 pues esto vale 0 entonces sólo me
va a quedar 2 pi
aquí sólo me queda 2 pi ahora cuál es
una anti derivada del coseno de pues es
seno de verdad entonces esto me queda
menos 2 seno de esto evaluado de 0 a 2
pi pero también fíjense en algo cuánto
vale el seno de 2 pi pues eso es cero y
el seno de cero también es cero entonces
todo esto va a ser menos cero verdad es
menos dos por cero es menos cero ahora
vámonos con las anti derivadas de esto
esto una anti derivada de un medio pues
es un medio
por uno
y ahora necesitamos calcular una anti
derivada esto va a ser
necesitamos una anti derivada de un
medio
la anti derivada de coseno de dos como
calculamos la anti derivada de coseno de
dos bueno si nos damos cuenta aquí
podríamos hacer un cambio de variable
digamos w igualados y ok y entonces la
derivada de w es 2 verdad entonces aquí
no tenemos el 2 pero podríamos
multiplicar por 2 y dividir entre 2 que
es lo que estoy diciendo esencialmente
déjenme ver donde lo puedo escribir
por ejemplo acá arriba un medio un medio
por el coseno de 2 y es igual a si
multiplicamos por 2 y dividimos entre 2
tenemos un cuarto o sea es decir aquí
multiplicamos por 2 para que nos quede
dos veces el coseno de dos y luego
dividimos entre dos que con este medio
se hace un cuarto entonces la ventaja es
que aquí este 2 es la derivada de esto
que está dentro del coseno entonces
podremos pensar que estamos simplemente
integrando el coseno de 21 verdad esto
es por el el cambio de variable en
integrales entonces una anti derivada de
ccoo seno de w pues es seno de w pero
seno de w es el seno de 2 verdad
entonces aquí sería seno de 2
y aquí ya no era un 2 dijimos que era un
este ya no era 2 este simplemente son 4
muy bien y ahora todo esto hay que
evaluarlo entre 0 y 2 pi entonces cuánto
vale esto en 2 p esto en 2 pues aquí si
ponemos dos pibes dv
si sacamos una mitad pues nos queda pi
verdad más un cuarto del seno de dos
veces dos pies seno de cuatro pero el
seno de cuatro pi es cero y ahora si
evaluamos en cero pues éste se hace cero
y el seno de cero también es cero por lo
tanto aquí ya hemos terminado y esto que
obtuvimos hay que multiplicarlo por este
un medio de aquí y entonces que es lo
que nos queda al final al final lo que
nos quedó es que tenemos un medio por
dos para más y es decir 3 pi entonces
este integral de aquí fue 3 pi entre 2
y esto merece al menos un primer redoble
de tambores porque ya tenemos una parte
de la respuesta que estábamos buscando
acá arriba verdad ya tenemos que la
integral sobre ese 1 es 0 y la integral
sobre ese 2 va a ser 3
sobre 2 entonces ya en el próximo vídeo
lo único que nos resta es atacar a esta
la superficie 3